- Get out of here Charlamagne !
This ain't Breakfast Club.
I don't think so.
(hip hop music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 298
of The #AskGaryVee Show
and we have a two-time visitor,
somebody I admire tremendously,
somebody I call a friend,
actually one of my regrets...
This is actually funny,
I just had this huge flight
to Australia and back,
you know, you just get 50 hours in flight
and you get to think
and I said in 2019, as we're
starting to get close to that,
one of things I'm definitely gonna do,
Oh Alex, I'm so glad you're in the room.
One of the things I have to
do is make a list of 12, 15,
19 people and I just have to have dinner
with them twice a year
because I'm just gonna die regretting that
there's these people I like
and normally they're are
people that get busy as well
and I don't know, we like each other,
unless we're showing
up on each other's show
it's impossible to like see each other.
- I know you only had dinner like once.
- That's right and so like
it's just always gonna be like that
and so like I said wow,
I'm gonna make a list
of just you know, maybe a dirty, maybe 12.
12 people and just say yeah,
we'll talk about it later Alex.
- Our first dinner was was popping.
We ended up with like Lenny Dykstra
or something crazy like that.
- Oh god, it got crazy.
(laughing)
You're so right.
Hunt and fish club, anybody
show up at any time.
Actually you know what?
I'm gonna put this, I want
you guys to go on live,
on Instagram as well.
I know were on Facebook live.
I'm gonna go Instagram live as well
because I want to get questions in.
Andy, I'm gonna do it a little different.
I'm gonna shout out right now.
I'm gonna wait for Instagram
to populate a little bit.
I'm gonna let the guests say hello.
Actually Charlamagne why don't
you say hello to everybody.
- Peace to the planet.
I go by the name of Charlamagne Tha God.
I am a father, a husband, and I guess
all the professional tags
that people care about,
a nationally syndicated radio personality
with The Breakfast Club, podcast host,
New York Times bestselling author,
Executive Producer of
a couple of TV shows.
You know, just happy to be here.
- You've been really, really
doing it the last five, six,
it feels like the momentum is substantial
over the last two to three years even,
but over the last half decade...
is that true, is that a
good observation by me?
- Nah, definitely a great observation.
You know everything's been growing.
Everything's been evolving.
That's one of the reasons that
things got very overwhelming
and I'm sure you can attest to this Gary,
when you're the go-to
person for a lot of people,
it's like who does the go-to person go to?
That's what made me start going to therapy
like over a year ago because after a while
everybody stopped having
the answers for me.
And you know flirting...
I like to talk to people who
are more successful than me,
most people that are way
more successful than me--
- Which you've done a
great job with, right?
I feel like you've been very...
one thing I don't do well
is mentor out, like I don't.
I just flat out.
- [Charlamagne] Really?
- Yeah.
- I think what you do is
consider the form of mentorship.
- No, no, I like to mentor.
I fucking love to mentor.
I love it.
I don't seek out mentorship,
I don't learn from a dinner
with Jeffrey Katzenberg
or Arianna Huffington, I don't.
I don't know why.
- Are you too busy talking
and not listening Gary?
- Yes, yes, but that's the fake answer.
The reality is I listen a lot.
If you watch, I cut off
'cause I'm listening.
It's that I listen to the mark,
I don't like synthesized points of view.
I like the market.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's why I want to go to Q&A.
it's why Instagram, by the way
now Instagram is populated,
Instagram/Facebook if you
want to get your question
and you're actually gonna email something.
This is different Andy,
I've got a new idea.
I want you to put your question
in the title of the email
and I want you to email...
Where should we send it?
How fast does it take us
to create an actual email
in this company these days?
- It better be 2.2 seconds.
- What do you got?
I mean you've got all sorts of
fucking emails we've made up.
All right.
- [Andy] GaryVeeTeam@vaynermedia.com
Gary V-E-E team?
All right.
GaryVeeTeam@vaynermedia.com.
Put it in there.
You can you can type it
in and pin it if you want,
you know how to do that?
You know how to pin?
I'm impressed.
Rag and shit.
It's Gary V-E-E team at Vaynermedia.com.
Put your entire question in the title.
Andy's gonna start looking
at that inbox right now.
We're gonna do a bunch of Q&A.
Actually also, actually put it--
- [Andy] They need to give their number.
- Yeah your phone number,
you got to be your phone
number in the body,
question in the title,
phone number in the body.
Got it?
Yeah, I don't do a good
job with that Charlamagne
and I'm proud of you for...
I actually again, you know
how well we know each other,
but just watching your moves,
just sensing even in our
interactions of watching out,
I think you're very good at that
and so that makes sense to me.
- 'Cause I feel like I
don't have a skill set
so it's just like for me
I didn't go to college,
I don't have any degrees,
like I kind of stumbled
into the game of radio,
so it's just like everything
else that's happening to me,
I'm not an expert at any of this stuff
so who am I to give
any advice on anything?
I just need to shut up and
listen for most of the time,
and you know, a lot of people that I saw
who were way more successful than me
they always told me how
they went to therapy,
how they talk to therapists.
I've been flirting with
the idea for a few years
and so I just decided to start going.
- Do you feel like the stigma
of it and the past culture,
'cause it's so great one
of the most exciting things
in my opinion--
- You go to therapy?
- I don't, but one of the
most exciting things for me
and I'm not against it and let
me make a very simple point.
I'm sure I will.
Because one of the
things is like you know,
it's moments in time but like no question,
one of the best things going
on in culture right now
is the stigma is melting very quickly.
- Yeah, it's interesting right?
- [Gary] It's huge.
- Yeah it feels like the universe is
conspiring for us to just have
these conversations about mental health.
By the way when I first
started writing this book,
I wasn't writing this book
from the perspective of
I'm gonna write a book
about mental health.
- By the way, real quick,
just so I can get it off my chest.
You wrote two fucking books
in like eight seconds.
- 18 months, yeah, yeah.
- Did you sign a two book
deal and you felt obligated?
- No, not at all.
- Did the first one go well
and you're like I like that,
let me do it again.
- First one did very well.
It was a New York Times bestseller,
it was on the New York Times list
for like seven weeks
straight so it did very well.
So you know how that is,
all the publishers start
coming to you pressing you,
hey, we want another book.
I'm like nope, I don't
do things for money.
I don't care what the check look like.
It's seven figures,
whatever, okay cool, so what?
I don't care.
If I don't have anything to write about,
I don't have anything to write about,
and I remember being on vacation
last year with my family,
something you don't do often enough Gary.
- I do a lot actually.
- You like to vacation?
Good, I'm glad to know that Gary.
- I take seven weeks vacation.
- Oh, that's beautiful!
- I think I've got...
2019 needs to be a year
where I clarify a lot of me.
I love that I'm blessed that
I love what I do so much
that I want to do it a lot,
but I have every weekend off,
I take seven weeks vacation,
I'm just going hard when I'm on the field
and I love my game.
And by the way and most of all,
I don't want anybody else to do that.
I want them to love what
they do as much as I do
and if that's working seven
hours a day teaching preschool
then you've won.
I think people associate and listen,
I talk a lot about work
ethic, you know what I am?
I'm so passionate against entitlement.
- Oh, 100%.
- That I think it clouds
a lot of other things
that I talked about or my truths.
- I remember you telling me that.
I remember you did tell me
that you do take vacations,
you do take that time,
and I remember you said
that's one of the things
you actually spend money on.
- 100%.
To me that's a great
thing to spend money on
because I'm so like I so want that.
Most importantly I don't
want to focus on anything,
but sucking out time with the ones I love,
so I don't need any time on logistics.
Like I don't wanna set up
anything or like just get me,
you know overpay for
everything to be frictionless--
- [Charlamagne] Perfect.
- Exactly.
And you know what's great about me?
Perfect is like if I have shitty food,
I'm not the one that's like fuck this.
What's perfect to me is I
don't have to do anything
other than be like you
know with my brother
or my sister or my kids,
you know what I mean?
My wife, you know.
- I like what you said too though
'cause I feel that way about success too,
success is subjective man.
Like if you're just happy
doing what it is that you're
doing, that's the win.
Like you could be living in
Charlotte, North Carolina
making $50,000 a year and your family
got a roof over their head
and everybody's eating
and you got a car and if you happy
doing what you love doing, you won to me.
- And by the way I think
that's not far away.
I feel like I can see in the same way
that if you asked me
six years ago, therapy,
I'd be like you know...
I'm starting to see two or
three people talk about it
that makes me, I think it's coming.
I genuinely think and I'd love to be
one of the thousand faces of
happiness needs to be the ROI.
Now at the same token we
can't demonize work ethic
because a lot of people
trying to do that too.
- I love it, I'm like you.
We love the grind, we love the hustle,
but when it's time to disconnect,
I like disconnected.
- Fair, me too but people are judging
people that are working a lot
and to me it's not about working a lot,
it's do you love what you do?
Like we don't do that to Beyonce.
We don't do that to baseball players.
We're doing it to entrepreneurs,
but we're not doing it to other people.
Elton John's working his face off.
He's 72 like out there every like,
because they love it.
Some small group of people
love either producing content
or being entrepreneurs,
the problem is
entrepreneurship got so cool
that everybody wants to be it.
It's the same reason that
athletes fail so much.
- You don't think entrepreneurship is
getting a little bit
easier nowadays though?
- I think there's more
opportunity because the Internet,
yes I do, but I think here's the problem,
everybody thinks
especially the young faces
that entrepreneurship means
I make a million a year
and to me entrepreneurship
and it's amazing,
big shout out to Breakfast
Club first of all
just 'cause it's an incredible program,
but that first time I came through.
Just appreciate your cosign
of like what I spoke about
but I appreciate Envy pushing back
because he didn't know me
and he's like wait a minute?
Like is this this typical you
know motivational bullshit?
- The white privilege guy
coming from a white privilege perspective
telling everybody life is
so easy, you can make it.
- And nobody knows my back story
so I don't expect anybody put in that work
and he goes give me something tangible
and it led to the flipping shit.
I don't know if you know
'cause you're busy as fuck
and you shouldn't.
- [Charlamagne] I see you
with your garage sales.
- It's getting crazy and Charlamagne
where it's really getting crazy is
what I tried to achieve on Breakfast Club
and what I'm trying to achieve
here, 57 thousand a year,
loving the thrill of the hunt at Goodwill
or on eBay or garage
saling versus 71 or 62
or 49 doing something you hate is
my dream of entrepreneurship.
Not Uber and Facebook and Instagram,
which is what everybody's looking at.
No, can you make more selling
the dresses you make handmade
then you would working as an accountant?
Can you make, by the
way, let's go big time.
Can you make 400,000
a year doing a podcast
and selling T-shirts versus
making 380 being a lawyer
and she's living a lifestyle
where she needs all 380
to pay for that lifestyle.
- Can you make a 100 thousand?
Can you make 50 thousand?
Like to me if you build
something from the ground up,
something that you created,
you work for yourself,
and you put it out there
and you got people buying your product
or buying into whatever it is you're doing
and you're making 50 thousand
dollars, that's a win.
- I've got a big one right now.
The one that I'm gonna really zero in on,
I'm gonna unveil it a
little bit right now,
if you make eight to 12 dollars
an hour and you have a car,
I need to push you to garage saling.
It's almost impossible
that you can't make more money flipping
than working at a quick service
restaurant or a retailer.
And as soon as I get done educating that,
anyway nonetheless, what's the book about?
- It's called Shook One:
Anxiety Playing Tricks on Me
and you know I've always,
I've dealt with anxiety my whole life.
I don't have the kind of crippling anxiety
that keeps some people
paralyzed in their house
just because sure you know--
- [Gary] You just don't.
- I just don't you know,
but I've always had--
- What's the worst you ever had?
- The worst panic attack I
ever had was nine years ago,
that's when I first got
clinically diagnosed with it.
I had just got fired from
radio for the fourth time.
I had to move from New Jersey
back to South Carolina.
I was living with my mom, I
was like 31, 32 years old.
My daughter was like two.
You know my now wife, she had
to go live back with her mom
and dad in Moncks Corner South Carolina
and I remember just driving
down I-26 in South Carolina
and feeling like I was
having like a heart attack,
like a severe like oh my god this is it.
Like Fred Sanford, this
is the big one honey,
like heart beating crazy
fast, shortness of breath,
even my arms felt like
they was going numb.
- Why, because you're so
ambitious and talented
and you're like at that point,
'cause I'm listening to the data,
you're like fuck I didn't make it?
- At the moment I felt like
I didn't know what was next
and I remember going to the hospital
and the doctor doing her EKG on me
and he was like yo, your heart is fine.
He was like yo, sound like
you had a panic attack.
He said do you have anxiety
and I was like no, not that I know of
and he was like I use
stressed out about anything?
I'm like fuck yeah.
- My life.
(laughing)
Mother fucker.
- So in my mind like most hustlers are,
I'm like all right, so
if that's what it is
all I gotta do is get back in position.
Once I get back in position
everything will be okay,
but then nine years later
and you're supposed to be great in life
like you know hit radio show,
making all types of money.
- [Gary] You're winning,
if you're not happy, right?
- Yeah I mean I'm...
happy is relative you know I mean?
- That's right.
And by the way if you're
happy 97% of the time,
but 3% you're really struggling,
that's already 3% too much.
- That's one thing I
learn from my therapist,
my therapist always says
just allow yourself to feel.
Whatever it is you're going through,
because you know we
come from, at least me,
I come from the law of attraction.
Your thoughts become things,
which I still wholeheartedly believe,
so like those negative thoughts,
that self-doubt, that insecurity,
you want to push that out
of your brain immediately
because you feel like if
you hold on to it too long
that it'll actually come to pass.
So for me it's just like you know,
I try to get that energy up out of me.
- Phone numbers, Instagram, Facebook.
Oh, I'm sorry, you got an email.
How are the emails coming in?
- [Andy] We got some good ones.
- Good.
Gary V-E-E at, wait, team Gary Vee.
- [Charlamagne] You just made that?
- No, we had it, what?
I'm sorry I apologize.
Gary V-E-E team at Vaynermedia.com.
Put your full question in title
and your phone number in the body.
Andy's about to call a couple of you.
Let me just stick on
us for one more second.
I've been thinking a lot about this,
which is why don't I judge myself?
Mm-hmm.
If you ask me why I stay way
happier than I think the norm,
it's because I think I'm
making mistakes all the time.
I always think I'm losing even
in what appears to be winning
because I am, I'm running a big business,
I'm doing a lot of things,
I see it every day.
We suck at YouTube.
(laughing)
No but you know like...
like I do so many things.
I was gonna buy unbelievable
amounts of Netflix stock
three years ago, the
phone call hung up on me,
on vacation by the way, hung up on me.
I didn't call him back, never did it.
See, I do fucked up shit all the time.
- Gary, you missed out
on some good shit man.
Netflix, Uber.
- A lot of things like
going to a business meeting
that I have to go to and
my kids have a recital.
- How do you handle that?
- Easily.
- Do you just feel like it
just wasn't meant to be?
- A hundred thousand percent.
I know what my intent is
and I know in a net score
loving them and showing
them how to be happy,
because I've met all the people
whose parents went to everything
and they fucking hate their lives.
Because I'm always like I suck and you,
I just think everyone sucks.
And it makes it easier, I don't know.
- That's kind of like,
that's a very pessimistic
way of thinking Gary.
- I just think it's massively optimistic.
Everybody sucks that, means
everyone's awesome, let's go.
- Now I do feel like my
father would always tell me
you're never as good as they say you are
and you're never as bad
as they say you are.
- [Gary] Well that's for sure.
- So I do exist in that gray area.
- Well there's another thing.
They saying hasn't been able to penetrate.
- Yeah 'cause who the fuck is they?
- I'm just like you can't,
here's why I don't take their judgment.
It's not that they're wrong and I'm right,
it's that they lack context.
Nobody knows what's
going on in my bedroom.
- The world is out of context baby.
- The world is out of context.
Everyone's throwing out
judgment now 'cause it's easy.
- Yeah 'cause of social media.
- 100%.
By the way, we always did it.
Now we just can read it.
People judged you in the streets,
people judged you in the office rooms,
people judged you at the cafes.
- You just didn't see it so much.
- [Gary] 100%.
- That's the problem too with the game,
you know for me it's just like
you get so much critique from
so many different places.
I think sometimes subconsciously
if you're not intentionally saying
I'm not listening to none of this shit,
subconsciously it will fuck with you
and it will manipulate you in some ways.
- Charlamagne most people
live their entire lives
dictated by other people's opinions.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Either your mom or dad,
which is the scariest one,
or the net score of
JohnnyPants47 in your comments.
- Yeah, I mean I've
gotten caught up in that
because like you know be
doing radio for 20 years
like especially over
the past six or seven,
you start reading all of these
magazine articles about you
and you see all these comments about you
and they label you things
like hip-hop's Howard Stern
or shock jock and this and that,
so you start thinking okay
if this is what people like
I gotta give them more of that.
- You become a caricature of yourself.
- You become a caricature of yourself
and I always say that's the worst thing
you could be is a caricature of yourself.
- Man, I gotta show you just
'cause I need to show you.
Look how many goosebumps.
I think about it every day.
It's my favorite thing about
actually running a business
and not being Gary Vee.
It's the reason I'm garage saling.
I'm going more to who I am.
I fucking love garage saling.
- The best part I think
or the best thing you
can learn from this is
being Gary Vee or being
Charlamagne Tha God
is like you're not being either
if you're not truly being
yourself at all times
and being yourself at all times is
acknowledging whatever it
is you're going through
in that moment, good and bad,
acknowledging the thoughts you have,
the feelings, everything.
- You're more of a manifest
it, I'm less of a manifest it.
I just was brought up by a mother
who never put her negativity
or issues on anybody else
and I share her DNA and
was conditioned in it.
I just don't share my stress.
I take on stress.
That's just who I am.
- Yeah, I try to use that anxiety,
I turn that fear into fuel,
like if I feel anything negative
I try to turn it into a positive
by helping other people.
That's what I realized.
I feel like I'm a public servant.
- My favorite thing is like
look, let's talk about life,
the life is very simple in a lot of ways.
People that look like you
doing certain things matter.
I'm the biggest believer in that.
- [Charlamagne] Okay, break that down.
- Yeah I will.
So I think when my grandma
used to do something
that I didn't understand when I was a kid.
We would watch TV and they would put up
Robert Goldstein Lawyer for John,
and she'd be like
(speaks foreign language)
and I didn't even know what
it meant for a long time
and after a while I
realized what she was saying
in Yiddish was Jew.
What I didn't and then I didn't like it
'cause I was like she was too,
like every time a Jewish person was on TV,
she'd be like yay and everybody else no.
And so I saw that as bad.
What I didn't understand until my 30s was
my grandmother lived in suppression.
She lived in Soviet Russia where
being Jewish was the worst,
where her husband went
to jail for being Jewish,
where that was the lowest on the totem,
because of World War II
and all that dynamics.
Anti-semitism, it's real in
Europe and I was like oh.
- So when she saw him on TV she was happy.
- [Gary] 100%.
- It was pride, she was repping her set.
- 'Cause she never saw it any other way.
- I feel the same way with black people.
- Of course you do,
which is where I'm going.
It makes me so happy
that you're going here,
because much like, there's a
lot of things that Russian Jews
and African Americans and Latinos share
and there's flashy clothes,
but one thing is like
not talking about these issues.
- Yeah it's a story I
talk about in my book
how they did a study on
descendants of Holocaust survivors
and how the descendants
of Holocaust survivors
have so much PTSD and anxiety and trauma
and I'm like y'all didn't do that study
on nobody else in America?
Like you don't think African
Americans go through that?
You think think Native
Americans don't go through that?
So it's just like for me is just like,
why not go do the work?
Like I work out three, four
times a week physically.
Why am I not putting that same type of
emphasis into my mind?
- I get it.
Andy, let's go with this.
This is so good man, this is so good.
I'm so glad this is getting
into the water system.
- Yeah, it's available
for pre-order right now.
(Gary laughing)
- [Gary] Get in there.
- And it'll be on October
23rd, be out tomorrow.
I don't know when this is
airing, when is this airing?
- So let's make sure we link--
- Are we on live now?
- We're live.
- Oh!
- Yeah, tomorrow.
- Yeah it'll be out tomorrow.
- We'll make sure, you know
how well the last one sold
'cause of our show.
- That's a fact, no, you're right.
- I'm aware.
(laughing)
We have a good crossover.
- Oh, so we're calling people.
- Yeah we're calling people.
Who?
Sherry.
Sherry don't miss your shot.
I love when they don't answer,
should we leave a message?
- Sherry don't believe
you're really calling.
- The best part is we leave a message.
- [Sherry] Hello?
- Sherry this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on The #AskGaryVee Show
with Charlamagne Tha God.
- [Sherry] Hey, how are you guys?
- We're doing really well, how are you?
- Hey Sherry.
- [Sherry] I'm good, I'm good.
Hey, hey!
- How are you.
- [Sherry] I'm good, I'm good.
So my question to you guys is
how do you overcome social anxiety?
Like I'm an entrepreneur,
I just started my own
web development business.
I've been in corporate
America for over 11 years.
So I have a lot of
experience in that field.
So far so good however
when I get in some things
to like you know close
on deals and contracts,
I get really nervous.
I start shaking, my lips start shaking,
my hands start shaking,
and I don't want them to just you know,
just look at my work and be like okay,
yeah she does really good work,
but at the same time I'm just so anxious,
I'm just so nervous like I
want them to take me seriously.
So what do you guys suggest?
- Yeah, go ahead Charlamagne.
- Well I believe in two types of anxiety.
I believe in irrational
anxiety and irrational anxiety.
so for you to be about to close big deals
and you're trying to sell
something to somebody,
you should have a little
bit of anxiousness
when it comes to that.
Like it's like me when I
approach the radio every day
or I go onstage to present something
like I know I'm doing
this to millions of people
so I'm gonna feel something in my stomach,
but what you have to do with that fear,
I got an acronym for fear
and it's face everything and rise
or fear everything and run.
It sounds like right now you're
being afraid of everything
and running, but you just
need to rise to the moment
in those occasions
because you're supposed to
get goosebumps when you're
about to close a deal
or you're trying to close a deal.
You're supposed to feel
like you got to take a shit,
you know I mean?
You're supposed to feel
something in your stomach,
so I just think that's rational anxiety.
I don't think it's
anything wrong with that,
you just got to use that fear as fuel.
- The other place that I think is
an interesting place to
go is, a couple things,
one, this is a self-esteem issue too.
You're making a very difficult transition
for a lot of people which
is the transition of
being an employee in a
corporate environment
for over a decade to being an entrepreneur
where it's all on you
and there is often times
self-doubt of like do you
think you're worth it?
Like it's your own self-doubt
being imposed on you,
something that might not even
be coming out of their eyes.
Does that make sense?
- [Sherry] It sure does.
- Yeah, so like to me,
let me give you a really
good piece of advice on this,
because that's exactly
what I thought it was
and this has really worked
for a lot of my team
that wasn't good at selling
and now is good at selling.
Never make a decision for the other party.
And value is subjective.
Do you know that I lose way
more pitches than I win?
Me, me, Gary.
Right?
And here's the funny thing,
when I lose them I just blame them.
(laughing)
Like I mean that, I mean it.
Like you just have to understand
like there's a million reasons
somebody's gonna say yes or no.
Let's talk about real life.
We live in a society now where
some of the disadvantages
are now advantages.
In the current climate some
people may give you the business
because they're trying to
diversify their vendors.
Good for you, you deserve it.
And you know what, you're
not gonna apologize for it.
- Nope.
- Right?
Some people might have
liked one thing you said.
Somebody might have not
liked something you said.
I've not given business to people
because I found that they were
Patriot fans, that's real.
I have not given people
business in the past
because even though I thought
they might be the right choice,
I hate the Patriots so much--
- That's petty as fuck Gary.
- The most petty, but it's my one place,
The Jets are my religion.
- Imagine somebody suing
Gary because of sports buys.
(laughing)
- Literally, literally, literally,
here's what I would say.
You have to understand
that them saying no to you
isn't because you stink or
because you're not good enough,
it's because there's a million variables
that go into somebody
saying yes to a vendor
and so when you become numb to it,
earlier everybody sucks, everyone's good,
you're just gonna...
- [Sherry] Yes?
- Listen you just gotta keep pitching
and after 200 of them
let's make a judgment.
You're definitely worthy of it,
you're definitely worthy of it.
You have to actually understand
Let me tell you why.
people are busy and there's
eight billion options.
The fact that you got into the final pitch
means you're ready worthy of it.
you have to understand that.
- [Sherry] Yeah, yeah.
- Do you do you see where I'm going?
- [Sherry] Yeah, definitely.
- Because you're not
looking at it that way,
you're looking at the final
call being the worthiness.
I'm telling you the fact
that you're even at bat
is the worthiness, now
you have to let karma,
serendipity, and a million variables
that you don't fucking control take over,
which lets you, let me
tell you what it does,
back to not being a
caricature of yourself.
Being very full circle
today, I'm feeling sharp.
One of the reasons I never
get too big on myself is
when I win, I also know its variables.
Yesterday they got yelled at
for not having enough social media
so today Vaynermedia is gonna
get the business not Ogilvy.
You see where I'm going?
- Or just as simple as this
person fucked with my idea,
this person didn't.
- 100%.
They thought you were funny,
they thought you were sweet,
they thought you were smart as fuck.
There's a million variables,
but the market decides,
but it's not a direct indicator
on who you are as a person,
it means your business at
that moment for that person.
The reason I can deal
with negative comments is
people haven't contextualized everything.
The reason you can deal with
not getting the business
is you don't go home and say I suck,
I should go back and get a
job, I wasn't good enough.
You need to realize it was
the serendipity of the moment.
- [Sherry] Mm-hmm.
You're talking about,
darling you're talking about
self-esteem, you know that right?
- [Sherry] I get that sometimes,
like sometimes I would think
that's probably what it is.
But then other times I'm like
maybe I just need to get out more,
maybe I just need to socialize more,
maybe I just need to get in
settings where I network more.
- Are you now saying to get more pitches
or to close the actual pitches?
- [Sherry] Just kind of natural pitches,
just you know just align
myself with more people
in my industry, talk about myself more.
- To do what, so that people
just give you the business,
so you don't have to pitch
or it gives you a better
chance of getting the business
when decision moment comes?
- - [Sherry] Just more so
she just work on my own self
when it comes it comes to speaking.
- Yeah, it sounds like she may be
one of these socially awkward Millennials
who was used to talking with her thumbs
so once she gets in front of people
it's hard to have conversations.
- I'll be honest Charlamagne, I love you,
but like I swear my life I
just think that's a cliche
like most 53 year olds
are that way as well
because what it all manifests down to
is a level of confidence.
- But it's hard to have it
when you're not in front of your keyboard.
- I get it but guess what--
- [Charlamagne] It's easier to have it
when you're on a smartphone.
- I don't know about that.
I mean I think a lot of people
get positive reinforcement
on the keyboard they
wouldn't get in real life.
- [Sherry] That's what, like you know,
because a lot of my feels like I said,
what comes from me being behind a keyboard
and so on and so forth,
but now I've just been getting to a place
where I'm actually, like people
are actually saying to me
like hey, come on in so that
we can have a chat with you.
Come in and show us your work.
- I'm gonna give you
something so empowering
that's gonna put you in a good mindset.
- [Sherry] Mm-hmm.
- Just go to all these pitches,
the best thing that can happen
to you is going 0 for 800.
Let me tell you why I'm
a good entrepreneur,
because I at six years old
rang people's doorbells
and asked them if I could wash their car.
That's just facts, this
is not the legend of Gary.
This is like bring out
everybody in Edison New Jersey
in '82 and '83, that's me.
Can I tell you something about that?
99 out of a 100 homes said
no to me right to my face.
And I was a cute six-year-old.
- All you need is one yes baby.
- All you need is one
yes and more importantly,
you get used to no.
You have to get used to no.
It's not what you're
wearing, it's not what...
it's not just not that shit.
It's moments in time
and if somebody didn't want to hire you
because of the way you
look or like what you wore,
I promise you it saved you time
because that's not
gonna be a great client.
- No don't mean you suck at all.
No really has nothing to do
with you most of the time.
- It just doesn't.
Just keep going, let
me tell you something.
Just keep pitching and keep
losing and get used to it.
It'll get real good.
You'll really start liking
and I'm telling you.
- Have you sold anything
through a pitch yet?
- [Sherry] Yes, actually just
closed on a really good deal,
a three-year deal.
- So what's the problem?
- [Sherry] With with a
company, but you know...
- But what?
- [Sherry] I'm sorry?
Everybody who's watching
right now is like fuck.
- Yeah, what's the problem?
(Sherry laughing)
- [Sherry] No there is no problem,
I just wanted to just
know like going forward.
- Can I ask you, can I
give you a different one?
Are you just lacking a little patience
because you want more?
- [Sherry] Oh no, that's not it.
- Okay, I respect that.
- [Sherry] It was really
just me just asking,
coming both you guys what are some tips
that you would want to
share with me going forward
when it comes to pitching myself more.
- I think pitching is the
closest thing of sports,
no different than going
live radio or live on stage,
and I genuinely believe a
little competitive anger
like fuck everyone is a good thing.
I mean it, I really do.
Like it's a sport.
Like you go in there and you're like
competing with those people
even though you're trying
to pitch to them, you know?
And so I don't know, like I
think Charlamagne said it right.
I still to this day
and I think I'm listen,
I think I'm real good at public speaking.
I'm doing at the top of the game.
There's always still the
three to four minutes
before I go on stage where I
get into a weird kind of zone.
- [Charlamagne] You feel
it, rational anxiety.
- That's a real good point.
Good luck, I'm fired up for you.
- [Sherry] Thank you so much.
- You've one, she's gonna win, she's set.
Next, that lady's winning.
Give me something more in between.
- I pitched a million TV
shows and probably sold
four or five, that's all I remember,
is the four or five I sold.
I don't care about the ones I didn't sell.
- Nobody remembers, everybody keep...
it's so, sports is so good.
Nobody remembers all of
Jordan's missed shots.
Nobody talks about LeBron
not breaking through anymore.
- [Charlamagne] That's a fact.
- That's just not the way it is.
- [Operator] Please leave
your message for eight,
zero, one, nine, one.
- Keep going, you know what I mean?
Like it's so like it's
just the way it is like--
- That's the problem with
social media too though
'cause social medias painting this
unattainable picture of perfection.
You see no losses on social media.
- I'm trying to put it, I mean I'm like.
- Social media is
everybody's highlight reel.
(laughing)
- Sure, but that's what
society's always been.
That's what we've always done.
This is about actually being
raised in an environment
respecting losing, that's
not what we do in America.
Who's this?
Alonso what's up, it's Gary Vee.
You're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Charlamagne Tha God.
- [Alonso] What's up Gary?
- What's up man, say hello to Charlamagne.
- [Alonso] What's up Charlamagne?
- Alonso, what's happening brother?
- [Alonso] Stay up, stay up, you know.
Just getting it like every Monday.
- What's your question my guy?
- [Alonso] Oh man, what's
the top three things
you guys do to keep your staff
or the people around you inspired?
It has to happen.
- I couldn't agree more, Charlamagne?
- What do we do to keep
our staff inspired?
- [Alonso] The people around
you, your staff, your people.
- Well if you got the
right people around you
then I think the right people around you
will understand that energy
is never lost or destroyed,
just merely transfer from
one party to the next.
So to keep my people inspired
I gotta stay inspired.
You know what I mean?
My people are a reflection of me,
so if my people see me slacking
or my people see me down
or my people see me doubting myself
then they gonna start doubting me
and then doubting why they work for me.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Alonso] Lead by
example, lead by example.
- Lead by example baby.
- I believe in that stuff man.
I think it's a great point,
but let me add something else
and it's really fun to have Alex
in the room right now,
it's timing is everything.
I do that.
Alex, how long you been on my team?
Alex has been on my team for a year.
I've Tyler and Alex as my admins.
We're completely lead by example, osmosis,
fucking throw in the
pool, learn how to swim,
that's just how we roll.
You're about to find out,
it's just the way we go.
However, I do think it's super important
when you want to when you
feel it or you feel something,
I the other day had to go out to the car,
it was raining, and I said
Alex come take a walk with me,
and just checked in.
Just that you know that that
nine-minute walk in the rain
where I gave her the
umbrella and just walked,
like you know I don't
want to speak for her,
but fuck, that shit matters.
It's just good to be heard, right?
It's good to be heard
and it's dynamics, right?
Tyler's the original admin, she comes in,
she's not sure like what my
interrelationship with Tyler is
or with Andy or with me like
so I'm a big lead by example,
I'm a big osmosis, I
don't like to micromanage,
but I'm a big fan of
the occasional check-in,
create an environment
where people feel safe.
I was thrilled with it
because I felt like Alex
was telling me the truth
or we did a lot of good in nine minutes.
It's just good to get it out.
It's also good for them to see that
you're paying attention to that too.
Otherwise they're just, otherwise
they're just collateral.
For me it's reverse-engineering them
and Alex may have different
ambitions than Andy,
and Seth may have different ambitions
and Seth may have
different ambitions today
than he did when he got on
the team a year and a half,
two years ago, so like it's
just watching them navigate.
What are they what are they about?
What makes them happy?
What are they striving for?
But look, if they're
gonna work as close to me,
which is unbelievable leverage,
yeah we're gonna have a
work ethic that's different
than the rest Vayner.
We're gonna have a longer term view
than the rest of Vayner,
but the dividends are extraordinary.
I mean Nate and Trouty..
I love those idiots.
- I love that man.
I love that whole mindset.
I love what Gary saying
because it's just like
sometimes you want your
people to know that
we work with each other
like you don't necessarily work for me,
we work with each other.
- I think I work for them,
for real, for real, for real, for real,
because I'm gonna do mine.
You know like to me like I'm
gonna do mine, I'm working.
I'm a doer.
Like you know I need
help like with things,
but like I think when you really think
you're working for them
and you're checking in
and look, you know,
like some people are good at
communicating, some aren't.
Some people complain about
everything, some have pride.
I'm a non complainer that
puts pressure on everybody
like if I'm never
complained about anything
they're scared to complain
about a 16-hour day,
but they're not me.
I own the whole thing,
they shouldn't have to,
but if they want to and
they're young enough
and they can do it right now,
it's gonna give them so
much leverage with me,
that's an interesting bet.
So I think you have to decide
how much you care about them,
for me it's everything
when it all plays out,
everything's different timing.
If you work in Vaynermedia
not on Team Gary,
you can get quicker
results for your hard work
with more short-term upside
and less long-term upside.
If you work on Team Gary,
you get less results,
I'm talk about pay and and like downtime.
Like you get less of that
upfront in years one & two
'cause that's just fucking the way I roll,
but you have me for life
after year three or four.
I'll fucking, I'll do everything for Andy,
for the rest of my life.
The only vulnerability
of that bet is if I die.
I'm not kidding.
- Is he in the will?
- Not yet but like, but honestly like
and for me the will is a
funny thing altogether too.
For me it's more about
putting the you know,
who's Andy of 52?
What's he gonna care about?
Like if it plays out the right
way, the way I want it to,
it's never about the will,
it's about putting people
in a position of doing,
back to happiness over money as an ROI.
You know like I don't know who here
wants to be a Dean of a school.
Let me tell you something right now.
Every Dean of every
College in 37 to 42 years,
I can place because the whole
game is gonna be reread.
Maybe they want to be a team.
- [Alonso] 100%, man
you guys stay inspiring,
you guys, Gary turned my
world around eight years ago
brother and why I love
Mondays because of you.
- Why?
- [Alonso] man I just started listening
and then I started doing
and then it turns off
for like six months and
then I turned you back on
every once in a while,
but I've been able to follow those steps
and learn from my team and
people and building it.
- Alonso, what's the biggest thing that...
what's the biggest thing that like
you completely were like
oh shit, 8 years ago,
what was the biggest thing
that I eliminated from you
through the content?
- [Alonso] Man, self-pity.
Blaming others.
I just switched it and
I'm like you know what?
if I'm gonna succeed or fail, it's on me.
100%, that's it.
Take responsibility and take
credit and responsibility
and give love to the people around you
that are there for you from day one
and just keep going, no
excuses, no fucking excuses.
- I appreciate it brother, I appreciate,
thank you so much.
- [Charlamagne] Love Alonso.
- And you know what's super
interesting about that?
You know even, here's the best part.
It doesn't mean that,
like when I say everything's my fault,
it doesn't mean that that's true,
it means that it's just a
happy place to think about.
It feels empowering.
You know like people get mad at me,
they're like Gary what
about, like you're right.
You know any of those things happen to me?
There's a million outside forces,
but like it's really exciting
to be able to think about
like I could possibly
do something about this
while to your point earlier,
still recognizing like
whether it's grieving
or being disappointed about it.
You have to be able to do that,
but it's just, to me it's
like what's the alternative?
- I think accountability
is very important.
Even if it may be outside sources
that are manipulating the situation
or are against you in a situation,
I still gotta realize like
what did I do in this?
- It's how you break through.
- [Poupee] Hello?
- Poupee?
- [Poupee] Poupee.
- Poupee, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Charlamagne Tha God.
How are you?
- What's up Poupee?
- [Poupee] Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
- What's your question?
- [Poupee] So if you're
stuck in a marital position
and there's issues where two people
are on different
entrepreneurship lifestyles,
one only believes in mirrors
and not helping their self.
Do you just say fuck
it, let's get a divorce,
go our own separate ways or you continue
and do your own thing and stay married?
- I didn't know you give
relationship advice too Gary.
- Hell yeah man.
I think this is all relationship.
- [Poupee] Hey, it's still business.
- It just very real life.
By the way I don't think most people
can be successful entrepreneurs
if they don't have healthy relationships
because the support system
for somebody that's trying to
make it happen is very real.
Look, I mean look, look,
it's never fun to sit around
and not know any context
and be like you should get a divorce.
Like that might make good
content, but that's scary, right?
Here's what I will say.
I think if you dig a level deeper,
that's where you start getting
into the interesting stuff.
Right?
I get a lot of men and women who hit me up
and they're like man my partner
is just like not about it
and not supporting me in any shape or form
and doing this, that, and the other thing.
And the question is is that an insecurity
or a shortcoming of the partner,
that it's a subconscious
misery loves company thing,
that's just very real in society.
- And also are you blaming
other emotions on the business?
Is he a good husband outside of
y'all not being on the same
page entrepreneur wise?
- [Poupee] Ah...
- Nope.
- [Poupee] I don't wanna put--
- Yeah, I get it, I get it.
Listen, by the way, you
don't have to the ahs enough.
- [Poupee] Yeah enough is
enough and the thing is look,
I let you do what you
do, you do everything,
I support you to 100%--
- Why can't I get that same support?
- [Poupee] Exactly.
- I believe in that shit man.
- [Poupee] If you see my vision
and you think there's success in it,
then why are you not helping me?
why are you not supporting me?
- So real quick, real quick,
helping and supporting are two different,
the way most people use the words.
Helping I'm okay with,
like if my spouse was like
I don't believe in that at all,
like I don't want to do the work,
like I don't want to give you money,
I don't want to pack
your packages at night,
I'm amazingly cool with that.
But not supporting emotionally,
not being a cheerleader,
or I call it cheerleaders and fullbacks.
Either you're gonna help me
clear the lane, so I can run,
that's packing the
packages, things of that,
or you're gonna be a cheerleader,
which is like blindly like
you could fucking do it.
If you're not willing to
do one of those two things,
you can't be the most
important person in my life.
- [Poupee] Yeah, that's
what I was afraid of.
- I just want to make sure that you,
like sometimes spouses are like yo,
my fucking visions on
point, you pack my...
like the eBay thing is
actually coming up a bunch.
They're like yo, I'm
doing it I'm finding shit
at garage sales and thrift stores.
I want my husband or I want
my wife to pack the shit
and ship, I'm like hmm.
You want them to do the shitty thing,
like and if they don't believe in it
'cause you shouldn't
believe in it, it's weird.
You just told your spouse
instead of making 78k year
being this executive,
Gary Vee fucking told you
that you can garage sale and make a hundo,
like they're scared, rightfully so,
because it's hard to get
to 78K in garage sale
and Amazon, you gotta get good.
But one or the two, if
he, and this is now macro,
if he or she is not
willing to be a fullback,
get in the trenches with
you or a cheerleader,
they're not in the trenches,
they're on their own shit,
even if they're lazy,
let alone doing something on their own,
they better be saying I
hope you're crushing it,
you're the best, you can do it.
If they're not doing
either one of those things
then what are they doing?
- Is that grounds for divorce though?
I don't know if that's
grounds for divorce.
I think you got other issues.
- [Poupee] No, no, it's
mostly the support issue.
It's just like when you're there
doing everything for the other person,
the other person just like
totally ignores you as a person,
it's more than just
because the business side
is just like he's a
straight entrepreneurship
or entrepreneur, but it's just like okay.
So if you're afraid that
I'm gonna be more successful
than you then I don't really want to be--
- He must got a little dick.
- Get out of here Charlamagne!
(laughing)
This ain't Breakfast Club.
I don't think so.
(laughing)
Yeah I think that correlation isn't true.
Like I've seen it too much.
I've been in a gym enough with people
that I think are emotionally stable.
Like I don't think that correlation
is as true as people think.
I think that what's happening
is the fact of the matter is
if you don't feel,
here's what I would say.
Is it grounds for divorce?
Maybe, but what you have to
have is a real conversation
of like yo, fuck you,
you don't support me emotionally for shit
and we're humans out here
and unless you're willing to give that
and if this is either out of insecurities
that I might pop and be bigger than you
or you just don't even give a shit
'cause you're all about you,
that needs to be a conversation.
- What you said is key just
now, emotional support.
It sounds like there's a
lack of emotional support.
That has nothing to do
with entrepreneurship,
you just want him to
support you emotionally.
- But it's manifesting in
the entrepreneurial game.
Go ahead.
- [Poupee] It's a lot because the thing is
I'm a stay-at-home mother,
but yet I still grind
like I do like not like
totally garage sale,
but I'm still working
on the full garage sales
that I did do a lot where I flipped like
a thousand dollars with a
baby clothes, kids clothes,
like it's easy, you know.
- Say that one more time.
- [Poupee] What?
- The easy part.
- [Poupee] Yeah flip the baby clothes
for like a thousand in like a few months,
not even six months and
like got a thousand dollars.
- Wow.
- It just matters.
Ugh, god this flip
thing is pissing me off.
- [Poupee] Like I get made
fun of because I'm like oh,
look I can flip that, I can sell it.
- Send them my way, listen do me a favor.
Everybody who makes fun of
you for flipping from now on,
in the history of your life
send a DM on Instagram to me
and that person and be
like yo, my friend Gary Vee
wanted you to make fun
of us in this DM, go.
- Yeah, how are they mad
at people for making money?
- [Poupee] My parents are a big--
- Put your fucking parents on there first.
Parents are the biggest fucking problem.
Parents are fucking the
biggest problem in society
because parents use children as collateral
for their own self esteem
and it needs to fucking stop.
- [Poupee] Yeah, most
definitely because for my kids,
my son I know he's not really
technically full college smart,
but we're working on--
- You know who wasn't full college smart?
Me and Charlamagne.
- Never went to college.
- I went to Mount Ida college.
I played Madden all day.
(laughing)
That's what I majored in,
Madden, Se-lo, spades, hearts,
flipping shit, I was doing it then,
that's what I majored in.
I wasn't college ready.
- I did one week of
Trident Technical College
in Charleston, South Carolina
and looked around the room
and said why am I here?
I need to be at the radio station.
Why am I here.
- And I looked around in the first week
and said this four year vacation's
gonna be the greatest shit of my life,
can't wait because I'm gonna
work my fucking face off
for the rest of my life.
- [Poupee] Yeah, a lot of parents
don't want their kids to fail.
- Because parents are insecure
and care about other parents
judgment on their kid.
- And they don't understand
non-traditional hustles.
You know what I'm saying?
My mom's a school teacher,
my father did construction,
I tell them I want to do radio,
they're like radio?
The hell is that?
- [Poupee] Yeah, I'm an immigrant.
My kids are first-generation kids,
so therefore the way that I
grew up is definitely different
and the way that I'm parenting
is definitely different
from my parents and
the thing is like look,
there's opportunities out there
and this is like the age of technology,
like you gotta get it.
There's like five year old babies,
they're out there getting it.
- Let me give you two cents,
do with it what you want.
I like everything I'm
hearing, for real I mean this.
Just over, listen, I can hear you.
Listen, I can hear you, your
being genuine as fuck with us.
Ready? One thing.
One thing, massively over
communicate with your parents
and your husband and everybody
else to put it on wax.
Put it on the record,
because a lot of people
just make these decisions,
I'm one of them,
all in their own head and then they move
and they expect everybody
that did something wrong
to just deal with the collateral damage.
Which is in my opinion fair.
What's even better so that you
have no regret when you die,
I want you to highly
consider being as authentic
because you're keeping shit in,
being as authentic as humanly
possible to all three of them
over authentic for the record,
the fuck you, I love you,
how can we do this, if
we can't, cool, fuck you.
That talk and then you can really move
because you're giving them
the opportunity to adjust
'cause they can't read your dome either.
Do you understand?
- [Poupee] Yeah.
And people like you and I,
because I can feel it already,
we're not as good at that.
Do you understand?
- [Poupee] Yeah.
- So you live with no regret,
one last at-bat to over
communication, for the record,
giving them a month or two
to navigate that new data
then make a decision.
- And she may need a mediator.
You might want to try a couples therapy.
Couples therapy might be good for you.
- [Poupee] Yeah, trust me
I've been there, done that,
I've exhausted every option.
- Y'all did couples therapy already?
- [Poupee] I'll just say the
only thing that he accepted
was therapy with his married
couple friend and that's it.
- Understood, listen, listen.
Here's what I would say.
- Man, divorce papers soon.
- Listen, listen.
This is super simple.
Leave one manifesto on
the table for perpetuity
between you and him
and you and your folks,
so that nobody's confused
what's in your head,
nobody, full 100% truth,
then you can navigate lightly as a feather
to happiness for yourself
and your kids forever.
- [Poupee] Thank you and I'm pretty sure
some people are gonna
figure out who this is now.
- I'm sure, I'm sure.
And people are watching
this show so you know.
(laughing)
Listen I wish you nothing but the best.
- [Poupee] All right, thank
you, you guys are real, thanks.
- Thanks, bye bye.
That was a great way to end.
- [Charlamagne] Wow.
- That was real.
- That was very honest.
- What's really about that
is what's real about this,
which is real about literally
the whole fucking conversation
which is very simply,
the Internet is gonna
expose everything anyway.
There's no hiding.
- So be transparent.
- [Gary] So move into it.
- We live in the age of transparency
and plus it's easier to wake up every day
and just be yourself.
- Charlamagne, we're gonna link this,
who should get this book, in your opinion?
Who's watching or listening
on the podcast right now
because we're gonna air
this in different times
or a clip from these things.
Who should pick up this book
and team let's make sure
we link all the books.
- Anybody who suffers from anxiety,
anybody who suffers from PTSD, trauma,
anybody who feels like they're
the go-to a guy and go-to a girl
and they don't have a go-to
person to go to themself,
'cause I'm talking about
a lot of the therapy
that I've been doing over the
past year in this book as well
so I just think it's for anybody
who's got any of these
so-called mental health issues
that they haven't chosen to deal with.
I chose to deal with mine.
- Good for you.
No question of the day,
that was just enough.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)